il vous arrive peut-être de chanter sous
la douche en voiture ou de siffloter au
travail la chorale populaire est fait
pour vous une initiative lancée par le
directeur du grand théâtre ouverte à
tous novices et amateurs chaque mardi et
vendredi soir les répétitions affiche
complet théodore de queiros
chanter ensemble
ben il ya une une vibration collective
qui se dégage qui fait que oui on est on
est bien
effectivement on sent de la joie dans ce
choeur de chanteurs âgés de 7 à 77 ans
voire au delà l'opéra de tours a ouvert
ses partitions au grand public avec une
chorale populaire aucun niveau musical
n'est requis pour y rentrer
les répétitions quant à elles sont
offertes deux fois par semaine quand on
prend des cours il faut aussi avoir un
budget donc je trouve extraordinaire
qu'on nous offre cette possibilité que
la direction de l'opéra nous non
pendant cinq mois le groupe d'une
vingtaine de personnes va travailler sur
un répertoire varié allant de charles
trenet à carmina burana ils auront même
l'occasion de le présenter lors de la
fête de la musique le 21 juin prochain
en parallèle l'opéra de tours continue
d'ouvrir son art à tous les âges y
compris les plus bas des concerts à
destination des enfants de 3 mois à deux
ans une manière d'éveiller les sens de
ce très jeune public moi ce que j'aime
bien c'est qu'elle entend de la musique
comme un spectacle vivant et que ce soit
pas une musique enregistrée ce soit
vraiment une musique interprétée sur
scène le tout justement orchestrée au
travers d'une mise en scène originale et
mobiles pendant 30 minutes les femmes
chantent au plus près des regards
hagards des enfants confortablement
installés sur les tapis ou dans les bras
des parents